yeah there's no way he's in charge he
had major brain surgery a number of
times being the president of the United
States is an extremely exhausting
stressful job that many presidents age
severely during their time in office you
look at the presidents uh maybe you know
people make arguments against Donald
Trump but you look at Obama you look at
Clinton you look at Bush they look like
totally different human beings before
they came into office and after they
came into office as years off of their
life have been taken away there is no
way he is slaving away there's no way
he's at that desk making the decisions
he's not in charge he's not calling the
shots the bigger question that people
need to be asking themselves is when
he's not there he's checked out he can't
even make coherent sentences who's
really in charge that's the question
that a lot of people should be asking
them Easter Bunny can we give a round of
applause to the onion for this time I
love to bring this article up that's
great the stress of presidency already
ages by in 10 years